how worried are you that what we're
seeing in the east is um the beginning
of the invasion so it's already started
it is a beginning of animation but do we
hope it will also end there so this is
where was also my main message because
we started and we will start with the
sanctions u.s uk as well as european
union and i hope this will stop this
kind of escalation and
putin will start thinking what he has
done
and what might happen in in future um in
the u.s and the uk have been very open
in the fact they built they do believe
that there will be a full-scale invasion
so do you disagree with that
i talked to ukrainian
prime minister and also to president
they don't think this would happen
probably they have their own information
sources so
what i can say is we hope
it won't happen so let's see
and do you think though that if
president putin is successful in
taking control at least of ukraine that
he could then turn his eyes
wider and maybe look at the baltic
states
as i said uh if he tries to look wider
he's looking at nato
and it's not the baltic states estonia
or any other country it's in nato and
that's
that's a different story as i said and i
guess the uk embassies moved why haven't
you moved your embassy from kiev
because
from
my opinion is that
ambassadors
and embassies should stay on the front
line in these kind of situations